you know life change
thank you um good evening everybody i
wouldn't use the microphone tonight i
don't normally um but there's a few more
of us thank you for coming to tonight's
external overview scrutiny meeting and
i'd like to welcome our colleagues from
north devon and thank them for taking
the time to join with us tonight
um
a bit of housekeeping just in case the
firearm does go off
you can stay you lot
but if you just make your way out to the
car park there's a fire assembly point
down there and the toilets are just
outside if everybody needs any through
the corridor there
um
i'm going to hand over to um councillor
york now who's going to just do um the
initial part of your meeting and then
she will hand back to me and we'll do
the initial bit bar meeting and then
we're going to go over to the
presentation
from southwest water first
i'll hand you over to council york
thank you
well thank you very much for inviting us
along to your uh our joint meeting um we
are members of the uh licensing and
community safety committee and there
there were some questions over what what
has this meeting got to do with
licensing but of course we do cover
community safety as well so thank you
very much for inviting us along uh so
i'll just do the initial part of our
agenda
so uh if i can ask you all rihanna
please how um how have we got an
apologies for absence uh yes received
chester's henderson hunt orange
and yesterday
thank you very much
um
item two item support board which is the
opinion of the chair should be
considered by the meeting as a matter of
urgency
i have nothing
uh item three any declarations of
interest
no thank you very much
item four to agree the agenda between
part a and part b
um well we have no part b so continuous
part a
item five is our joint meeting with
torridge district council regarding
south west water and the environment
agency presentations
okay yeah thank you
okay i'll just do our first bit of the
um agenda apologies
generously
we'll just do the minutes of the last
meeting that's okay i'll take them page
by page
um i'll go by the page number at the
bottom
page three
shout if you've got anything
page four
page five
page six
page seven
page eight
one line on page nine
anybody happen to propose those
councilor lever seconded by councillor
harding all those in favor
abstentions
come on
against
no thank you
um we have no public participation this
evening i thought we might get some i
don't know
not tonight
um
i'll just skip through the action list
thing that's really much up to date
um 91 is complete through to
118.
updating the forward plan obviously we
haven't got anything on there at the
moment we might all stop places at the
next agn that's on the
16th or the 11th
16th of may
[Music]
oh yeah we've made contact with mid
devon but i'll update you on that a bit
later
council language
that will be on the forward plan still
and
um the alamo that's still on the forward
plan
and
done
that complete complete
that's what i like
there we go that wasn't
done the action list sorry
and any declarations of interest
no um item number six which is agreement
of agenda is part one of part two we
have no part one
no part two i know
just saw the two on the end
that's why i didn't say 11 but there we
are and
urgent matters bought forward mission of
the chair i have none
um consideration of the forward plan
i think we'll need to consider that at
the next meeting to see whether i'm
still in the hot seat
and then that brings us on to item
number nine which is our joint agenda
item and i think we have the south west
water first
environmental agency i thought the
gentleman from southwest wanted to be
first he did but um
[Music]
yeah i think he also wanted to join a
little bit later because obviously we
had the two agendas so he's not really
here you mean i've been a bit quick
but
he's not in the waiting room no it's a
update from environment okay we're going
to go with dave from the environment
agency first
so we're going to go
have the presentation from the
environment agency they've had the set
of questions that was given to them
forwarded to them
previously so we're going to hope that
these questions have been answered
within the presentation mostly if they
haven't then the environment agency will
take questions after their presentation
and then the southwest author will take
questions after their presentation
hi thank you um you wait
speak you're right if i share my screen
yeah
okay
this will work
would you just like to introduce
yourself as well because um
not everybody knows you
uh okay um my name is dave travola um
i'm the team leader for integrated
environment planning at the environment
agency covering
devon and cornwall
um
can i just check that you can see a
slide
because i i can't see what's being
presented at the moment
and it's called the role of the
environment
that's that's good the other option was
you see my emails which probably
wouldn't be so good
okay so
yeah thank you for um the invite
and for the questions raised uh
beforehand
what i want to do with this one is run
through
the role of the agency so
an overview of our statutory framework
that we operate under
our planning framework
and how we then go on to use that to
deliver improvements which is probably
the bit that you would be
more interested in
it's not going to work for me
so our statutory
role
we work on the statute and that that
gives us our roles and responsibilities
so we work primarily under things like
water framework directive um and that
includes the shellfish and bathing water
directives and the new um environment
act 2021
these various different pieces of
legislation set out our duties and
responsibilities
they tell us how we are to monitor
the targets we are to achieve and and
the actions that we can take as a result
of that
in order to enable the legislation we
have a number of plans that are put in
place from the basin plans or flood risk
management plans through
more relevant ones to this topic
drainage and wastewater management plans
and those plans set out the ambitions
the outcomes we're seeking to achieve
and some of them include indeed who we
would like to work with and how we can
achieve some of those
and an example of that would be
the program of activities that we enact
through things like the price review
also known as the amp or the winap for
various different guises of that
that planning cycle
um
and that sets out the the mechanisms and
the programs by which the funding
time scales by which we can achieve uh
some of those and we also clearly also
have sort of direct regulation um and
enforcement activities
and along the way
new duties such as the environment act
can come along and and
those things take time to become ways of
working um
so i know one of the questions was
around how the aim of
ensuring water companies can secure
progressive reduction in discharges from
csos well in terms of filtering the
intent of the legislation into a way of
working that takes time to come down and
for death for instruction policy and
process
my suspicion and that hasn't come
through yet my suspicion would be that
it's most likely to to utilize the
existing mechanisms that we have around
the water companies the the environment
programs
that we have there
and some direction on how we can improve
or enhance regulation in order to meet
those aims
um but first i thought
i think we have to accept that um csos
and emergency overflows these are our
necessary features they are necessary
design features
um from our sewers in order for them to
work properly and there's many reasons
why these can
can discharge whether that be
design faults or design not keeping up
the appropriateness of development
or just accident blockages and
breakdowns
they are designed so that they
operate within
certain criteria
and they should be operating when they
have access flows
but those
systems can also fail
or discharge for uh misconnections
surface war innovation from groundwater
faulty sewers so there's a whole raft of
reasons
um and there's an increasing demand on
some of our infrastructure so that the
resulting changes from the pandemic with
the change in working from home or
staycation tourism
and we can't overlook the impact that
the climate change is having on the way
our systems operate with more intense
rainfall coming along it provides
a different pressure on the systems to
the ones they were designed for with
high intensity rainfall
um so if we
sorry could you just um say what a cso
is i'm not sure if everybody in the room
knows okay sorry yes sorry acronyms um
combined sewer overflows
and eos are emergency overflows
um so
yeah if we can accept that these are
actual necessities within the systems
it's our role to ensure that they are
operating
in the ways that do not cause
environmental harm
and one of the ways we can do that is
through event duration monitoring and
this is a
an increasing monitoring program that
the company are having to install the
water companies across the country are
having to install
in order to monitor the operation of
storm overflows whether they be
emergency ones or combined sewer
overflows
um and it's by
this monitoring increasing over time so
the monitoring started in 2016 all the
installation of monitors started in 2016
and is gradually improving across the
system
to the point of over 80 percent being
monitored now and with the
um commitment that the the all of the
csos and eos will be monitored by the
end of
of 23 that's a commitment on the on the
water companies
and if we do increase monitoring then we
can expect to find
increased occurrences it's the same as
saying you know vehicles speeding
um
you don't know their speeding unless you
put a camera up and catch them
and so it's it's really the same in some
respects with
the operation of the sewerage
infrastructure
that um the increased monitoring is now
giving us an improved awareness of
how these systems are operating
um as monitoring itself lends to
raising issues
um
making that more widely available
ensures that other organizations can
have their view and indeed members of
the public generally can have their view
um
so
that's one of the reasons why we're
getting
more information now
and people becoming more aware of the
situation is because we are now
monitoring more
companies are monitoring more so we are
identifying more
operating and issues with the systems
to the point where
back in november of 21 the environment
agency and off what launched
one of the most significant water
quality investigations
um that we've ever had uh into the way
our sewerage treatment works and the
sewer systems are operating
i think because of
because that is an ongoing investigation
in some ways i won't be going into
site-specific detail necessarily in case
it would prejudice that investigation um
and and
um so this will be a relatively general
talk but it does highlight the fact that
it's not just the environment agency
that has responsibility for overseeing
water companies or for themselves being
the economic regulator whilst the
environment agency or the environmental
regulator
um and then you also have like the
drinking water inspectorate from a clean
water aside
there's also parts to play for local
authorities for pressure groups as well
from a political and
legislative change angle so
we're all kind of responsible but in
terms of legislative responsibilities
the main ones are the environment agency
and and off what
it all it does feel a little bit
sometimes as if we're bashing the
company um when i make these sort of
presentations and i don't think we
should leave it at that i think it's
only fair that we should recognize
the improvements that have been made
over the years
through the programmes that have been
well over the last 30 years really with
the amp programs and those have been
predated largely on our coastal waters
on bathing waters and shellfish waters
because of the nature of our area
and there has been
says there 1.4 billion pounds worth of
investment
so far in cleaning up our crude sewage
discharges to treat ineffluence
um
we should understand there's still work
to do and we all accept there's still
work to do
whether it's from environmental change
or from legislative change
um and the the
environment is becoming more of an
interest to people and society generally
um
so which is only a good thing and that
keeps the pressure on and ensures that
we don't uh
don't rest on our laurels or assume that
we've completed the tasks before us
um because this is for
storm overflows
and water quality
the maps there
show on the right hand side the location
of the venturation monitored storm
overflows
and their spill frequency and there's a
bit of a close-up for the for the s3
itself to show some of those that are
kind of overlapping on the main map
this isn't a reflection of compliance in
any way that's not the point of the map
this is the
counting the spills and the location of
some of the sites
and often
asked if these are all
permitted sites well they they should be
uh it's the simplest answer but as the
investigations go on um we find more or
people report more they there's always
an opportunity to find outfalls that we
are unaware of
um
that haven't been permitted and when we
find those we were the company to ensure
that they do have the appropriate
permits in place
those
permits that do get put in onto the
locations um
they will have conditions stating what
flows are supposed to be in coming to
the site
before they're allowed to discharge
conditions on them that have eventuation
monitoring installed and as i said
earlier the vast majority of the
locations do have that now with the
further commitment to
complete all the sites by 2023
and that those data
from the sites can be supplied to the
environment agency for compliance
checking um and
and
that is what does happen um and that
should be in the permit for each of the
sites ultimately
the majority of those
overflows do now have venturation
monitoring as i mentioned earlier then
the commitment for 2023 is there
i would and i see that alan's now joined
so i this is the first time i've
mentioned you i promise um the surface
water would be able to provide
site-specific
information and details on those
environment agency operate with a sort
of a summary level of information
um so if you want site-specific
information i would have to direct you
to the
to the company themselves
and i remember that one of the questions
was how many spills have there been into
the torridge
over the last 12 months yes 12 months
well
not the last 12 months but in 2021 there
were
1290 spills that discharged into the
river torridge
across all of those
monitored sites that you see on the map
there
um so i and i've already said i can't
really comment on
specific locations
um
for fear of prejudice to the case that's
ongoing um so i won't be
saying any more
about that
the questions were largely around water
quality and the impact of sewage and
discharges onto bathing waters and
shellfish waters
well bathing waters and shellfish waters
are both protected areas under the
framework directive
therefore our our requirements for
monitoring um and the mechanisms for
improving and laid down as i explained
earlier in the legislative requirements
that we have
but the standards that we apply to those
those um designated areas
are the same as where when we were part
of the european union
the legislation was directly translated
so we've not got any different standards
at the moment i probably should say
there's no guarantees that they will
stay or what they will become they could
become even tighter
so we're operating under exactly the
same
regime in that respect as we were before
it's not a single sample compliance
when we assess the compliance with
battling waters though it is an
assessment across the whole season
um and across the four
rolling four years so no one sample
causes compliance or non-compliance
it's an assessment across
a number of samples taken during the
season and over the four years
it's
fair to say that there's been an
increase in
wild swimming or as we used to call it
swimming um so that
people are calling for
uh monitoring outside of bathing seasons
monitoring at places that are not
designated
um we can't do that without the
legislative change we haven't got the
driver to
to monitor outside of the building
excuse me outside of the bathing season
um but
there's an increasing
pressure um and connect from
the public to their environment locally
certainly since lockdown in particular
and
the answer
really is that anyone can designate a
bathing water if they suggest whether
it's a coastal one or an inland one
but
we can't do the monitoring unless it's
in the designation
process
um
the most recent bathing water
classifications was a success for devon
cornwall and all of our bathing waters
achieve required standards
um through
2020 2017 through to 2021
so that's that's good news
um
for the shellfish waters there's a graph
there in the corner which shows the
trend that is generally improving
shellfish water and quality
um
deffered don't publish shellfish water
compliance annually
there are
these results are included in the river
basin management plan and
shellfish water action plans
if anyone is
is interested but they are still on a
general trend upwards not quite where we
want them to be but still improving
and somebody asked a very specific
question about the impacts of all the
sewage discharges on fish populations
um
and also
general river pollution and agriculture
which i'll come on to in a minute so the
map now on the left here indicates
latest fish compliance for the framework
directive so blue being
high green is good
uh yellow will be moderate
the gray ones are are not routinely
monitored
and the
map on the left
if you can see the little blue squares
they have to actually have a fish in
them and those are the fish monitoring
locations for this coming year
and the table just explains why they're
being sampled
so that's where we will be monitoring so
there isn't a direct indication that the
impact of storm overflows or surge
infrastructure is the reason for not
achieving good in fish it is more
typically barriers to migration
than it is
and it's probably worth
distinguishing between
fish compliance as in what we have to
report or the framework directive saying
this is
fish as a subset of that is compliant
where
the compliance is based on
[Music]
expecting to see a species and finding
it when you do the monitoring which is
slightly different to the sort of
fishery and what people feel and see
when they're out whether or not they can
catch fish anymore or whether or not
they see fish where they used to see
fish that is subtly different to the
compliance from a fish point of view
so it's not necessarily wfd being
compliant it's not necessarily you can
still catch fish like we're used to
which is often what people say to us um
and you have to
reflect on many other aspects
certainly around some other fisheries
when you're talking about many other
influences on declining fish stocks
there from the north atlantic into
coastal fishing or whatever it might be
before we can have a true picture of
that
regard the overall
uh pollution and agricultural if you
look at the graph at the top
you can see there they're broken into
the local authorities and these are the
reasons for not achieving good status
underwater framework directive
and you you can see by the color bands
that
the predominant
problems we have
are a mixture of diffuse pollution and
point source pollution
and
diffuse pollution is
typically agricultural land management
and some small sewage work type
discharges
and
the point source
whilst it's predominantly water company
also in includes industrial discharges
and other larger private discharges so
it's not all all the water company
and the graph on the bottom is a
breakdown of the agricultural proportion
of the top
graph which shows that
most of the influence from agriculture
is coming from
poor livestock management or nutrient
management
or soil management in varying degrees
depending on what your farming type and
your land type
is
and
i think this with this and with the um
[Music]
the incidence of storm overflows
it always helps if people do report and
quite often we get oh we've always got
problems with this site or that site and
when we look back and see what it is and
when we get asked what we're doing about
it and we look back and see what we know
about the sites
it's often that we haven't had anything
reported there for a number of years uh
and it's hand handy if people do report
so
i remind people that there is a
pollution hotline
number there's a no 800 number and it's
80 70 60.
and it's simple so that even i can
remember it
so
i i would urge people to continue to
report incidents
so that we can use that as evidence when
it comes to building up how we can
actually approach the problems
chair can i ask a question or is it
appropriate to ask a question
on that slide i think we've come to the
end now so we're going to take questions
thank you for your
very good uh presentation thank you for
that i'm just interested in those top
bars
between
plymouth and exeter
and given the other rural districts
which have a lesser density population
for the landmass um why is there such
colours in plymouth that are not in port
bay and extract i just wondering what is
happening in plymouth that's not
happening in extra or bay
they are
they are pretty much the same colors
um they are still diffuse problems and
that is um misconnect that's often when
it comes to a rural catchment that's
often missed connections and highways
drainage and things like that
um
but they are
but if you take plymouth i mean that's
fed by about five rivers if i remember
rightly
um and a lot of that is a hint of
a rural area but yeah
have any any agricultural pollution from
that very declared personal interest
because i own former i suppose just
being clear um it's interested that
they're not picking up any um
agricultural pollution there in their
their
surveys no and they will be reported
more under west evan south hams
rather than within the the actual
boundary of plymouth city council
which which would be mainly the the sort
of sound
uh and the title estuary parts
so when you talk about the reasons for
non-compliance you're talking about the
impact on the actual water body where
it's occurring so most of the streams
that feed into what you might call the
plymouth area
are actually within other people's
boundaries so they'll come out in west
devon and
south hams in this respect
thank you thank you
anybody else have any questions today
check and i ask with regards to the
questions that we submitted are they
going to be addressed by selfish water
or environment agency today
um
but i know there was one specific
question
that came from yourself
[Music]
[Music]
this is from mr buck it's a specific
question that wasn't quite covered in
your presentation
he would like to ask why the pollution
of northern burrows here in westford
home is allowed to continue
there's a couple of parts to it whenever
there is an overflow of untreated sewage
from the drains of houses in gulf lakes
road eastbourne terrace as well as
fenton drive
when they experience
[Music]
is downpours your question mary yes i
mean the manhole covers are pushed up
okay and sewage is spread over the
bubbles
without with other sanitary bits and
pieces and mentionables it ends up in
the ditches those dishes then feed out
to the history and to our oceans
and there is a big risk to people that
use the bowers and horses and cattle
graze there
and that's what would really you know
worry to a lot of people that use it is
that something you can
answer uh some of that yes i mean what i
was going to say on my my last one is
that i i'm hoping that i have answered
most of them if there are any specific
questions that i haven't answered or you
haven't noted the answer to
what i would do is i will return
on the questions that were sent to me if
i if it's okay karen if i can return
them back to yourself
with some more detailed answers behind
them
um i can do it it's probably better if i
do it that way um some of them i will
not be able to answer because they won't
be our remit um
and some of them i might not answer if
you bear in mind what i said about the
ongoing investigations and whether or
not i want to say too much about any
site in particular
but i
i will answer all the questions that
came
um back to yourself if that's okay where
i can
i think you have covered most of them
dave i've been taking them off right
okay i thought somebody would be keeping
track
well i can't
assure you that it's spot on but it's
i've had a good go anybody else any
questions counselor brenton and then
councillor woodhouse
thank you chair um
well personally uh i struggled with that
presentation i have to say you can see
it very well um
i presume it's going to be printed out
as it
will be circulated
or printed
um
interesting user phrase not bashing the
company and it was
one of the problems when
water was privatized about how the
relationship between the environment
agency and
work
i always thought then we have a problem
with it and i do believe over the years
there still is actually
um because i'd like to ask how many
prosecutions you've taken out against
water
for uh non-compliance over well i don't
know many years you tell me roughly what
sort of prosecutions you've taken out
i i do not have an answer to that i'm
afraid um
i don't know whether allen does or not
but i wouldn't even begin to guess
um
but i mean in terms of the relationship
with the company
it is
the two parts to it i suppose we have to
work together with the company
in terms of delivering activities around
the improvements of the the amp scheme
that sort of win up
so those investment programs
um we have to work in conjunction with
the company on that
that is often mistaken for
working for the company or working too
closely with them but we still have a
regulatory arm and we do still take
enforcement activity where that is the
most appropriate and the best use of
resources and or public money in order
to do so
because we have i mean the enforcement
needs to lead to an improvement and if
the improvement is actually better
delivered
by
by working through the processes that
already exist on the other half of the
conversation
then it's reasonable i think to do it
that way um so we have two relationships
with the company the one where we do
work with them and the one where we
definitely do continue to take
enforcement action against them
is that something you could find
accuracy
i can find out the number of cases we
have
taken
over the last few years yeah
wouldn't that be great is that would
that be okay
would be a starter pretend it would yes
but the the thing is how uh many other
organizations department is organizing
here uh do you actually uh have to
do presentations too in terms of what
environment agencies are doing
um i used to be a member of water voice
which i don't know if you recall that
it's the government disbanded that some
years ago
and we did have both
settlers water and environment agency up
before us once a quarter and all these
sort of questions were
put towards them and they had to provide
the answers but i don't know what has
replaced that i struggle on the internet
find out what exactly has replaced that
because it appears no
uh body which actually holds environment
agency and satellite
we are held to account by by defra um we
are held i can assure you we're held to
account by pressure groups
um quite often
um this is the
fourth presentation i've given in the
last couple of months on this subject
to committees such as yourself and to
different partnerships
so
it is still being
um talked about in question
um
thank you
cancer
please
thank you chair um thank you dave for
your presentation very difficult to
follow as somebody's already said
because we're
sort of looking at a screen in your real
way so it would be appreciated if this
is fortunate
you've made great play of the 1.4
billion
invested
in the last 32 years
trying to get context about what would
the profits of southwest water have been
in that time period
this gentleman's from the environment
agency
i did that's because that is the amount
invested so far as a result of the
improvement programs that we work with
the company on
i can't comment on how much i
don't know but i wouldn't comment even
if i did know on the amount of um
profit the company has made
i think it is relevant if you're using
the one point preview chat relevant
using that one point four because i make
it about in a year but my mouth is not
great
um just over 400 in a year
doing this the area of southwest water
yeah
do we feel here as an agency bill that's
enough
i think i said there's always more to do
there there is always more to do with
more money more resources on our side
and all the company side
we could achieve a lot more
but we have to work within the
constraints that we do have
thank you
to that question
just wanted to know how that funding
compares with what funding you had say a
decade ago whether it has gone down
um it's
constantly gone up each it's operated in
five-year funding windows and each five
years has had more
as as the remit of the improvements has
grown from
to include more
aspects of either biodiversity or nature
recovery
so the so the investment
uh value has gone up steadily and i
think the this year again has gone up
considerably on last year's that the
last five years sorry
um i just wanted to
find out a bit more information about
the ongoing investigation that you said
started in 2021 um it i mean you said a
few times you don't want to sort of go
into too much detail
um i just wanted a bit more information
about who who is carrying out and when
it is anticipated to finish
um what i will do i will answer the
question but what i will do is include a
link
with the answers i send back to karen
that will take you to
more information on it so you can read
as much as you like
um investigations being carried out by
ourselves and by off what
um and it is progressing um in terms of
time
that as with any investigation not just
environment agency ones depends what you
find and how long it takes you to work
it out doesn't it so
it will progress at its a at its pace
but it's regret it is progressing at a
pace being driven by or for ourselves
but i i will include a link so you can
go to the gov information and awful
information on how it's progressing
okay
councillor haynes please
yeah thank you for speaking to us
tonight i have a couple of things asking
you to comment on first there's a
letter from the environmental lawyer
down in south heaven knowing something
eastern charlie hopkins who you may know
metabolism regarding indiana navy waters
and creating the environment agency for
a consistent failure to enforce the pec
bathing water directive
um
regarding bathing areas to dishwashing
is traditionally practiced
by a large number of babies
he berates the agency for consistently
failing to enforce that
since the 1990s
and wonders what
the situation is now we've left the
united only eu
and suggesting that failure is due to
the uh water companies trying to protect
their profits
and the other question um
used recently that the environment
agency has said that there weren't
attend
to smaller incidents
lesson board against
start when you said
who there was a letter from somebody
about the bathing water and our failure
sorry left from the guardians from the
environmental lawyer charlie bobkins um
you may know um regarding inland water
from the
failure
eu
enforce them
right
so
we don't have any inland bathing waters
um to enforce there has been one
designated up
country now
um but we don't have any i know some are
being investigated
but we don't have any at the moment so
we wouldn't have
any compliance activity around in that
bathing waters
[Music]
work um it's not initiated by the
environment see it's initiated elsewhere
quite clearly sorry i i couldn't hear i
can't hear what you're
yeah how does it work there's a
designation does it have to come from
other sources rather than environment
agency
yes yeah we we don't designate bathing
waters um
anybody can designate a bathing water
any individual uh it has it kind of has
to be supported by their local authority
and there is a designation process
whereby you collect information around
numbers of bathers facilities available
to bay there's parking toilets bins that
sort of thing
and survey
the bathers that are bathers that use
the site you then enter into a
designation process once in the
designation process the environment
agency are obliged to start monitoring
and we start monitoring then for
compliance so that when the bathing
water gets designated assuming it does
get supported by defra
um
we have the monitoring data then to
start the compliance
checks for that bathing water
so
no it's not us that designates them it's
us that monitor them
so the process we one can find out on
on the environment agency website
presumably
yes yeah it's actually on the dot gov um
another link i can include
um it's on the dot gov and it's a guide
and a forum to fill out
to start the process off
um
so if i if i include that back with the
answers again it can go out and if
anybody's interested they can follow
that and look at what they have to do to
to designate
is there more counselling the
the news that the environment agency
isn't investigating
what they consider to be
very important
pollution incidents can you comment on
that
they can i can comment that that news is
correct um and it's been publicized that
due to resourcing constraints
within the functions that perform
those activities in our our instant
response
are such that we we can't go to
everything everywhere
and therefore we're having to prioritize
the ones
the the reports we do have
that
require
the most urgent attention
so what do people do if you don't attend
do they consider them to be important
it's a matter of
time taken for you to look into it
i'm i'm sorry but i couldn't
i can't i can't quite hear what you're
saying
yeah i mean if you don't consider them
to be of importance lots of process
you say prioritize so it's a matter of
time the environment agency attends
the situation or it just doesn't have to
attend at all
it's
it's most likely to be not attend
um but we do keep an eye on the number
and types of reports that come in
whether it's by location or by type
so that if we do get us
if we do get the feel that there's a
significant number of incidents or there
is something worth
elevating
escalating
our approach to that particular aerial
report then we will do so
but on a first call
it gets assessed within the call center
it gets triaged by
an on duty officer
and they make a call as to whether or
not it's it's
sounds like the right category to go and
investigate
so basically it's a question of lack of
resources when it comes down to it
yes yeah it is it is a resource-driven
um response that the agencies have to
make it's a national response it's not
one that we've taken locally
um
and it's on the back of
what our chair says to therefore quite
often you get the environment you pay
for and if we don't get resourced to do
our full duties we cannot do our full
duties massive government cuts in other
words
oh yes
significant cuts in funding over
years that has led to
um not being able to to commit fully to
the some of our responsibilities
thank you councillor pearson
um that's very much the comments i was
going to make actually about resourcing
and how seriously
do we as a country
take the
impact of this sort of incident on
environment which is causing degradation
of that environment it's a time when
we're supposed to be increasing
biodiversity and improving things so
what can we do
what can the environment agency do what
can any of us do
to bring that up the agenda
somehow because this is not acceptable
presumably do you do you have a
five-year plan a 10-year plan indicating
what you need to do what resources you
need in order to achieve
the outcomes that will support
mitigation of the effects of climate
change
we do have plans we have flood risk
management plans we have river basin
management plans we have um
the 25-year plan
we and we have local income plans now as
well that we're
that we put in the outcomes we wish to
secure um
and those
debates arguments requirements do go to
defra each year and we ask for money
each year
and
um
we'll then as part of a defra family
um funded
appropriately
to their
sense
and i've got on top of that we also get
funding from our charged income from our
permitting and from our abstraction
licensing for waste licensing
um but it's the element that
funds our incident response and some of
our regulatory work doesn't come from
those
um funded
incomes they come from the grant funding
that comes out of defra and that's the
bit that's been slashed over the years
now my point is that you're saying
that's been slashed and and
how seriously can we take the
environment and that's the question that
that fundamentally lies on the
anthologist sure
it is a question that i cannot disagree
with you on and it is a question that
our
our chair and our management often ask
of defra
when they go to them and say can we have
some money please
and that's the questions they put you
know
and that's why he has said quite
publicly
you get the environment you pay for and
then if therefore don't pay for us then
we don't do certain activities
we can only we can only ask and they can
give or not give
and we would obviously appreciate
any pressure from local authorities from
um
from pressure groups that
i mean we don't mind people highlighting
the fact that we're not doing all of our
role
because we're not doing it for a reason
um not doing it because we don't want to
we're doing it because we just can't
and if people highlight that then
then we have to welcome that and we have
to welcome the challenge around not
doing our
jobs properly as people put it
thank you um councillor please thank you
thank you dave i'm your bet governor
from kumarton
um you've probably heard of us and i'd
like to say thank you to you the ea and
to save west water who have worked
constantly with us
for many years to get our baby water
quality right we'll sort of get in there
eventually
and amount of money that has been put
into kumaratin
just like to say on a positive note
thank you very much
i'll definitely accept a positive note
thank you
you're just scared about
we have it with ea and and it's worth
putting a group together to work with
the ea and southwestern
all these issues we've been for many
years
it does and it feels sometimes like it's
never ending and
um but it is tendermint to the fact that
you know we have to do these things
together
um you know we have to we have to work
with the company we have to work with
community we have to work together in
order to achieve things we can't
necessarily always do it at loggerheads
or
working in our own silos we have to be
more open to working across each other's
organizations and with the public
well through that process we've had
quite a lot of money spent in ku martin
um from the southwest water and you know
we may be there i think
we will get some good results
thank you councillor
did you finish today are you okay i'm
finished thank you yes
um unless there's any other burning
questions
um i think we ought to move on to um the
southwest water presentation just
looking at time and i know the other
gentleman
was quite pressed at the time for
himself
so finishing on that positive note thank
you councillor
um
and thank you dave for your presentation
thank you
if we do have any other burning
questions um i'll get the members to
email them to karen and
she can forward them to you yeah that'll
be fine thanks thank you very much for
taking the time tonight to come and
present to us really appreciate it
i'll stop sharing now and listening to
alan thank you
now if you want
oh hold on louise i want to say
something yeah i'd like to say thank you
so much as well very much looking
forward to seeing your the full answers
to the questions um just wanted to
finally ask whether any of the north
devon members were satisfied with the
question answers today and happy to wait
for a full answer
yeah happy to grateful for yeah thank
you very much indeed
thank you
are we ready
[Music]
can hear us alan
yes
yep i can hear you can you hear me
i think he only pops up when he talks
hello can you hear me
yeah um
if you just like to introduce yourself
and you can start with the presentation
and then we can ask questions after if
that's okay with you
absolutely i am not familiar with zoom
so i do apologize can you see a
presentation there
[Music]
uh
it's not yet
okay um let me just work out how to do
this i've only used two ms teams i do
apologize
let's see how this works
i'm on share screen it doesn't appear to
want to share anything
let me just check
and then i think it opens up your
desktop and you can find where you've
saved your presentation
[Laughter]
let me just find my presentation
torridge district
presentation slides i'm hoping this
might be
it
bear with me a moment
my computer's not responding can you see
those slides now
so
hello david good to see you again david
and i worked uh for many years together
so um i'll just do a bit of introduction
my name's uh
alan burroughs i'm director of
environmental liaison culture at
southwest water
um believe it or not i was 31 years with
the environment agency up until february
last year when i joined um southwest
water
in order to help them deliver their
environmental performance plan and
improvements um over this am and
preceding um asset management period as
well so
i'm going to talk through my
presentation in in my presentation i
will cover some of the questions
which um david has already covered so
i'm hoping i will give exactly the same
answer to some of those but some
apologies if if i do contradict i may
hopefully be able to add some additional
uh information to what david has said so
i'm going to press the
down screen button now no
is that next slide come up you need to
expand your presentation it's just
fitting we'll park the screen
oh gosh okay um
employee show
option somewhere
[Music]
the attachment
okay let me just try something else a
moment apologies for this ladies and
gentlemen
all right
let's go to slideshow
from beginning
can you see that now
okay
i think you need to stop sharing the
screen that you are and select the one
that you've opened
okay i'll do that
let's try that
can you see that now
yeah
we can only see you
oh
[Music]
oh dude apologies
[Music]
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna have to
apologize i'm gonna have to um
um what i'll do is i've got set slides
here and i will go through these um for
the sake of time i've got a presentation
that i will provide um afterwards okay
so unfortunately you'll you'll have to
look at my
look at my face and listen to my voice
but hopefully what i say is more
compelling than maybe some of the um
some of the diagrams okay
okay
uh i
can do that but unfortunately i've got
some notes that are my notes under under
the thing so i'd have to revise the um
the presentation because there's some
notes for me specifically
can you zoom in on the screen
[Music]
okay i can't see any of you know all i
can see is my screen so um i don't know
what's happening i do apologize so
i'll start again um hi my name is alan
burrows um i am director of
environmental liaison culture at
southwest water um i was previously in
the environment agency for 31 years so a
lot of what david has
presented i'm very familiar with
and i might be able to add a little bit
of flavor to some of the things that
david has also said as well from my my
time in the eaa and up until recently
um i was also uh responsible in the
environment agency for our instant
response nationally as well so i may be
able to answer some questions around the
uh triaging of incidents that i think
one of the one of the councillors raised
as well so um
um thank you first of all for in
inviting me um i'm just going to talk a
little bit about southwest water itself
just to set a bit of context so
we've got some 2 million customers
serving um
more than kind of 10 million people
during the tourist season within
southwest water
some stats and facts we've also got 19
000 kilometers of pipe network
we've got um in the region of 1100
to
1300 um storm overflows where we are
planning to um
put invent duration monitorings on by
the end of 2023 and i think david uh
alluded to that in his earlier
presentation
um we've also got
in the region of
635 sewage treatment works
and
hundreds and hundreds of sewage pumping
stations across devon and cornwall
we've also taken responsibility as well
for um the arts of silly recently
and we're working with the australia
council in order to make improvements um
in the water infrastructure on the
valves of silly
so that gives you a feel for a little
bit about the size of southwest water
i think one of the things i wanted to
also say is we're also committed to
net zero commitment by 2030 so in
everything we do now we are we are
having to consider our impact on on
climate change
so that by 2030 we'll have a net zero um
impact on carbon
um and that means that we need to do a
series of things uh firstly decarbonize
our fleet
and go 100 electric
switching from fossil fuels
looking at um
greener ways of um producing electricity
not only from our assets but from others
as well
but also looking at um other things that
can impact our carbon emissions and that
is how we treat waste how we pump waste
reducing leaks
etc etc
and then the final thing is looking at
how we
can mitigate some of that through
tree planting um so there's many things
we can do
i think
for me i i heard david i'm not quite
sure at what point david i came through
your presentation i suspect around about
20 through but i'm hoping i can answer
some of the
some of the questions that i heard some
of the counsellors um raise in in your
presentation so um this week we
actually launched um our environmental
strategy and today susan davey um our
chief executive
and ian vosberg our wastewater services
director are with off-what
to um
try and um
get off what to understand the
opportunities and challenges we have
within
southwest water particularly on back of
the
um
continued emerging and increasing
interest in the environment as a result
of the recent
coronavirus outbreak and the lockdown
and also
supporting what david said the issues
around
further increases in the environment and
wild swimming or swimming i think as
david uh called it
so
um
i have a i have a vested interest in
what we do i'm a prey cornish man i've
lived in the south west for all of my
life
and i've also worked the environment
agency so some people might say well why
do you want to go and work for southwest
water
simple answer that is my values remain
very rooted in the environment i think
the environment is incredibly important
for everybody we might not believe it
all the time but it actually is and
that's why i chose to to move to
southwest water to help them
improve their environmental performance
so i'm going to talk about water fit
we've got six
themes in water fit first one is
nurturing healthy rivers and seas
um and you're probably thinking so what
does that mean alan i can tell you
exactly what that means what that means
is we are committing to reducing our
impact on rivers by 2025 by one-third
and to put forward plans to reduce this
by zero to zero harm by 2030.
we're also going to be reducing spills
from storm overflows to an average of 20
per year by 2025
and we're also going to be managing the
um excellent bathing water quality
standards all year round so in answer to
one of the councillors questions it's
not just about the bathing season you're
absolutely right it isn't just about the
bathing season and so that everyone can
enjoy the 860 miles of coastline that we
have
and we're also committed to delivering
zero serious pollutions by 2025 and some
of you who may have um seen the recent
press or um articles on gov dot uk we
have had serious incidents in the past
but we're now targeting to reduce those
and the next one is putting nature on
everyone's doorstep
and that really is to make sure that
we make bathing um bathing water
accessible to everybody in the southwest
so people can drive less than an hour
to get to a bathing water what that
might mean is that we might want to work
with others who may wish to propose a
new designated water to look at what are
the opportunities to
meet whatever bathing water quality
standards are required for an inland
water
and we're doing some work on the dart
and tavi to understand what those
impacts are
and we're going to be putting additional
monitoring in there to understand what
we need to do what we need to monitor in
order to determine whether or not um
proposing an inland water is feasible
both technically and we can do the
monitoring in order to protect that
baiting water inland
the next swing is looking at creating
and restoring habitats
some of you may be aware that we'll be
doing significant amount of work looking
at restoring
peat
on
dartmoor and exmoor we've been working
very closely with the environment
agency's biodiversity team looking at
how that improves not only water quality
but can also reduce flooding improve the
water resources availability and also
improve the net capture of carbon of
carbon sorry
um so we are planning to
increase our activity and actually plant
a further
quarter of a million trees by 2025 to
help combat climate change
the other thing we are going to be doing
is to
ensure
that um
the
that we stop or help to mitigate
pollution from 120 000 hectares of
farmland um
by working with the farming community
in order to put in schemes to enable
diffuse pollution to be reduced
um the next one is um
number four is inspiring our local
champions so we've been looking at how
we fund communities and what we've what
we are proposing now is to donate 25 of
our community fund to local groups
that share our passion around river and
sea health
and i'm really pleased to hear the
counsellor from north dev and talk about
the work that we've been doing to help
the community in kuhn martin
to enable them to achieve the
required standards to meet bathing water
quality for [ __ ] martin beach
and we'll be focusing a lot of that as
we move forward
the final two are creating sustainable
future
and that really is about working
collaboratively collaboratively with um
developers
working with local authorities and
planning authorities to make sure
that new developments are created in a
sustainable way
what do i mean by that to make sure that
any new development separates its
surface water systems from its foul
water systems in order to ensure that we
only treat what is necessarily needed to
be treated
in addition to that we are working on a
campaign to ban
non-flushable or plastic containing wet
wipes and i'll explain why later
because they can cause a significant
impact
on our sewage system and eventually
cause an impact on the environment
um some of you may have also heard in
connection to that are um
[Music]
are uh campaign called love your lou um
where we continue to promote the three
p's
pee poo and paper that's all we should
be putting down the loo nothing else
should be going down below our systems
were not
developed to take anything else other
than those
and then finally it's about putting
people back into control
giving people the information they need
to understand what's happening in their
environment
and some of that relates to what we've
recently done working with the
environment agency on the back of the
increasing concerns around storm
overflows
where we are um
continuing to
provide information to
the environment agency and others
through our event duration monitoring
information which shows when our
monitors where our monitors are and
david showed a a map of that
the operability are they working all the
time are they working some of the time
the spill data when they're operating
how often and for how long
um and that information is available on
our website for all to see
so that's kind of our our commitment um
i think it's really important also just
to give a feel for why we have storm
overflows traditionally they were there
to
prevent
properties being flooded during
heavy rainfall events there's nothing
worse than i've seen it
when i've been to
communities that have been flooded
particularly when i was in the
environment agency many that i remember
the 2012 flooding incident at braunton
22nd of december remember that very well
where a number of properties did get
flooded
um i was there with the environment
agency on television for about three
hours talking to sky tv itv channel 4
bbc
and a number of the other news outlets
and i had the opportunity to
actually look at the impacts that
flooding can cause and it's not very
nice
but the reason why we have csos is to
minimize that impact
that said
as a result of that uh if it doesn't go
into the house it does get released
through our storm overflows
and and can can have an impact on the
environment and i i think i heard david
mention earlier on that um not it's not
necessarily the storm overflows that
cause the impact on the environment and
i think there's a really interesting
debate to be had around environment
health and public health and i think
that's where the crossover conversations
sometimes happen particularly where
people have an increasing um
interest in in wild swimming
so what are we doing until 2025 um well
we're investing 330 330 million
into wastewater services up to 2025
and we're going to be significantly
reducing the impact of our storm
overflows on the environment
we will then i suppose the test will be
what impact has that had on
environmental improvement what impact
has it had on visual improvement what
impact has that had on customer
expectations public expectations etc etc
um but we're currently working through
where we're going to create where we're
going to make that investment to improve
those storm overflows
next i'm just going to touch upon some
of the questions that you've raised and
hopefully i won't contradict what david
said i think i caught him as he was
going through those questions but um
a number of questions were raised ahead
of this meeting
the first one was
the location of all storm overflows in
directly or indirectly into the river
torridge
um yes we have all of that information
available david gave you the map
if you look on our website you will find
everything related to storm overflows
and you will find information on grid
references the water bodies in which
they go into and that information is
freely available to everybody
and
one of the questions the next question
was are all of these permitted by the
environment agency
the answer is yes they are all permitted
by the environment agency
where they are not permitted is because
we don't have one there yet or one we
had
a cso that that was operable but no
longer is because we blocked it up and
we've done something to the system
therefore that cso no longer operates
and the permit is withdrawn so all csos
um are are permitted by the environment
agency and through that permit as david
said that then that then creates an
obligation on ourselves at southwest
water to report the performance of those
csos
we do that in three ways
ad hoc
if the environment agency are
investigating a potential pollution
then we are obliged to provide
information i think to your team david
actually in your um
integrated environment planning team if
there is reason to believe that there is
a pollution that's been caused by one of
our assets and we provide that
we also provide information on an annual
basis
um
because that's what's required by the
permit and that information was recently
um
submitted to the environment agency and
we have also published it on a website
alongside a report which explains what
event duration monitoring is
to support that information
and thirdly we are also required to
provide information on the back of the
bathing water season
so
around about november time we provide
information on all of those csos storm
overflows that have the potential to
impact bathing waters
and therefore may have an impact on
compliance of that bathing water
and on top of that
we provide information on ad hoc basis
on requests from journalists members of
the public
uh mps anybody that wants it because it
is environmental information that is
available
um so that information is there for
people
um
one of the other questions was um when
will all the event duration monitoring
be installed within your specific area
the answer is they'll all be installed
by december 2023 we've made we've we've
agreed with that obligation and we will
ensure that that is um
done
the other question i think david
answered this one as well um i'm hoping
i'm going to repeat a very similar
figure
um over each of the last three calendar
years how many spill events have
occurred at each location
how long have these combined spills at
each location lasted and what total
volume of storm sewage has discharged at
each location i'll answer the last
question first we do not measure volume
we measure start stop and we measure
duration
[Music]
that's not to say that at some point
volume may be a requirement because
volume is important in terms of
understanding
the the nature of the discharge
and its impact on either a larger or a
minor watercourse
so i think it's a watch this space in
that regard
and we are currently um proposing
problem statements and working with a
number of research establishments to
understand how we can
how we could
measure volume in an accurate way
and to enable us to understand what
those impacts are
um total number of discharges in
torridge actually decreased in 2021
compared to 2020
um
primarily weather related because as i
said earlier on the number or the
the the csos were traditionally built in
order to
reduce the risk of sewer flooding in
people's properties so when it does rain
heavily the csas tend to operate more
often
and i will remind
you the councillors that we have made
that commitment to
reduce spills to an average of 20 per
year by 2025 and
to
target zero horn from
csos on rivers by 2030
one of the other questions was um had
there been any notable edm breakdowns at
any location in the last three years
um what i can say is 19 out of 24 storm
overflows
um have edms that have operated at 100
of the time in 2021
only three fell below the 90
operability
but the average operability for all of
those was over 90 percent
recently the environment agency has set
a target for edm's to operate 90 percent
of the time
the next question was um and i'm going
to read the question as it's written
rather than interpret
which quango is responsible for
monitoring southwest water
and how do they connect with the general
public
david covered all of these points but i
will repeat it as we've been asked the
question as well
we have an open dialogue and meet
regularly with our regulatory bodies off
what to begin with the financial
regulator
deferrer and the environment agency the
environmental regulator
drinking water inspectorate
the regulator to ensure that drinking
water is provided in a safe manner the
health and safety executive to ensure
those things that we do are done in the
right way
but we also um meet with the consumer
council for water
and we also meet with a representatives
of
various stakeholder groups as part of
our water future panel where we can be
where we can be questioned about the
activities that we undertake and whether
or not they are
um providing the benefits that we have
planned to provide
um
the next question uh was on cornbread
um can uh cornbread wastewater treatment
works except um finite volume of sewage
at any time
during rainfall events storm sewage can
be released through
csos is increased residential
development
contributing to the frequency of these
spills
um
i'll answer that question in three ways
firstly any new development should have
a separate system surface water system
from foul system
um that should be part of the planning
condition and therefore as part as a
local authority we would be looking
towards the local planning authority to
ensure that those conditions are part of
the planning
planning conditions
um as a result of that if you separate
surface water from foul sewer the actual
proportion of um
liquid waste let's say coming from a
household is actually very small
the problem we have is when surface
water gets into it
and that's when we see uh instances of
cso's spilling
so yes we do take account of it
unfortunately we're not a statutory
council t
in the planning process like the
environment agency
but we do
take into consideration
and we constantly scan and we constantly
look at
the strategic plans local plans and
particular developments that may have an
impact on our ability to treat sewage
the the other i think there was another
question on investment so um
we are going to be investing around
about 2 million pounds during this year
on wastewater treatment to meet future
likely requirements
particularly around biddeford fine
screens where we've had some issues in
the past
and there was a related question
to biddeford fine screens and that was
does southwest water and i can't comment
on the ea but does southwest water
consider there's adequate storm sewage
um
eg at victoria park to offset spills
the answer is yes there is sufficient
storage
and there was a second storm tank
installed in victoria park in
2014
this was designed on the basis of the
understanding of known future
development
that said
if it's not operating in the way that it
should be operating the data from our
edms and our csos will tell us that is
the case
in addition to that the environment
agency can also review our data and they
can ask questions of ourselves regarding
the operability of those particular
sites
um one of the other questions was the
environment act 2021 aims to ensure
water companies secure a progressive
reduction in the adverse impacts of
discharges from storm overflows
i've just uh i outlined earlier on our
an environmental strategy called
waterfit
where we've made commitments to reduce
harm on rivers
by a third by 2025 and to reduce it by
zero
uh harm by 2030 we believe we are the
first water company to make such
commitments
and as i said earlier um susan davey our
ceo was meeting with off what today
to ensure that we
were able to
describe our environmental commitments
but also to
um
enable offer to understand what that
means in terms of our funding because
some of these commitments were not
funded in pr 19.
finally one of the other questions
related to the pollution at the northern
boroughs
in westwood ho
um i think one of the councillors sorry
i forgot the council is named was asking
about
um eastbourne terrace as well as vent
and drive
we have looked through our pollution
incident recording system and we don't
have any records of any such incidents
we believe some of it may be related to
highways drains and misconnections
but to go back to what david just said
if you do believe there is a pollution
that is occurring
and you believe it may be
as a result of a southwest water asset
i would offer a counter number
to david zo 880 70 60 and that would be
to run ring southwest water direct on oh
three four four three four six twenty
twenty because as soon as we know about
it we can do something about it
you may also choose to ring the
environment agency as well
the other question was on the cold water
swim trend is constantly gathering
followers you're absolutely correct it
is and i i think i'm one of those
followers now but i tend to swim in the
sea not necessarily in the river um can
we do away with the idea of the swim
season i've interpreted that as a
bathing water season an attempt to
improve water quality throughout the
year
um
that is a that is a
legislative
driver
but we've already committed to maintain
excellent bathing water quality
standards all year round
and in fact we operate um
62 sites with uv disinfection all the
way all year round and six sites
specifically in north devon and you will
probably know the sites i'm going to
mention which will be williken freud etc
um
the there was another question from uh
councilman malcolm
wilkinson the member of uh coastal
communities would like to know
how discharge of raw sewage is affecting
bathing water quality
we have two of the poor bathing water
readings from uh from seven nationwide
um
we have no poor bathing waters in the
whole of the southwest region
we had 100 compliance for the first time
ever last year and we know that kuhn
martin was previously a poor bathing
water that actually did achieve a
satisfactory status in 2021.
on the back of that and i'm pleased the
councillor mentioned the work that we've
been doing at queue martin
we have been working really hard with
stakeholders in the local community and
with the environment agency to
understand the complexities around the
ku martin um catchment to see what can
be done in order to maintain the
sustainability of the bathing water
quality at [ __ ] martin
and what even we find in that very tiny
catchment it is an incredibly complex
picture to get your head around there
are many many contributing factors but
we have managed to achieve satisfactory
status this year
um in addition to
the work that we've been doing in the ku
martin catchment we're also working with
a number of research
agencies and
a colleague from david's team is also
involved in this looking at smart
metering that uses smart technology to
understand real-time information about
catchment
in order then to work through what we
can do in real time to improve water
quality in a particular catchment
it's early days it involves artificial
intelligence and computer modelling i
don't pretend to understand it but it's
a very powerful tool that i think will
prove to be very successful as we move
forward in the future
so i suppose my take-home messages are
that
we're doing a lot within north devon and
torridge
really pleased that the results of the
work that we've done in particular
patches within north devon and torridge
have started to show some benefits
particularly around q martin but i
suppose we can't do it on our own
we need the local authorities to ensure
that the planning process is appropriate
and that the planning process protects
the environment in the way that um we
can work with new developers in order to
stop any increases in pollution
incidents
um more globally though we are working
with water uk to
try and ban the uh use of wet wipes and
i'll just give you a little bit of a
statistic here for
the southwest water region
[Music]
last year we removed 450 tons of
unflushables or wet wipes
cotton pads etc etc
um
which is equivalent of 30 double decker
buses
um
if we don't put it down the loo it won't
find its way in the environment
it's a very simple message so
everybody has their part to play
and i think that's it from me chair
i can take some questions is there any
questions from anybody i will present i
will provide the presentation i do
apologize for my inept use and zoom it's
not familiar to me
okay that's fine actually i almost think
it was more engaging in that
presentation it made me stop and
actually look at you rather than
look at the slide
thank you so much
because some of it um yeah
from david's spreadsheet she was a
little bit small we couldn't quite see
it so um it will be good to forward that
one as well
um i'll open the floor to questions if
that's all right
councillor hardin
um
good evening um
it's good to hear that uh you've had a
lot of success with uh uh two morning
now i'm a ward um counselor for
heartland and within heartland i have
fox news
now bucks mills uh
has been designated for
cleaning the water up and the sewage is
going directly into the river
and it's going at the waterfall and
people are showering after a good day
surfing under the waterfall and um i was
just wondering
it's been two
two and a half years now since the
application has been put in which was
forced by the environmental agency the
clean water statute and also
um we've put it through as our our local
parish council and it's two councils
it's part of our rosary
um and uh there's properties down there
that want to be sold but can't sell
because of this hanging over them
and we're still waiting for word whether
water authority or waterboard is going
to take it uh to do the
the um the improvements uh do you know
anything about this
particularly about buxom improvements
well they they've they're all about the
treatment works up in the car park and
then um
taking all the sewage up from the
properties which is about nine
properties um and probably about four or
five others that need to go in there
because they're they're probably not
good enough
uh okay i i i understand i understand
the question i can't give you an answer
to that um uh if if you can
if the chair can ensure that that
question is
relayed to me after the meeting and any
others that weren't raised ahead i will
ensure that our response is provided to
that i don't have the detail i'm afraid
we can do that we'll forward it to you
thank you very much uh next of court
cancer derek speer ah thank you um i'll
take a question at the end but um
um
alan mentioned
he worked for environment agency
and myself i was
as a county council i was on uh
environment agency for flooding
and also in the environment and he
mentioned
the allen mentioned the flooding of 2012
in bronson it comprehensively flooded
the village
it had overran the sea defenses which
had only been not the land defenses
which is only put in like two years
before
um
the middle of the village was four feet
of
water and the waters were going
in all
directions um
but
but
the
environment agency responded brilliantly
all this happened every friday and
saturday and my wife before two days
before christmas but my wife was then
chairman of braun to paris council got
the environment agency act
the next day
and then in the catholic principle the
prince of wales came
as well
and they have done through the
resilience fund
and goes through the county council
brilliant job
we now have a
up state-of-the-art pumping station
like underground pumping stations the
water through kane
and we've got the county to get rid of
the victorian drainage and that
and that
has been
done as well
we have a lot of training in what the
shops should do to prevent flooding
and we in fact um produce the parish
working with the environment agency and
everyone else
a resilience
emergency plan which in fact has been
shown
as an exemplar to other people at the
moment the system hasn't been absolutely
challenged so having said all the
respondable things i keep my fingers
crossed
but there are good things going on and
also in addition to that the 25-year
plan for flooding and um
and also the pollution that's going on
and the pollution
issue does worry very very much and we
now have leaky dams one of the major
tributaries coming into um
the river cane of bronton at first when
we talked about newton's plans with the
public thought we were mad but it's the
system which stops the water coming
through very quickly and it drains
slowly away and that reduces
considerably the
flooding and
i know also i um there's this hundred
year plan about the seed defenses which
we've got it important
as well
but the next
thing and i think it's an
environmentally
working southwest water is to the
pollution which is in our rivers
because i'm also a great fan of the
local artists um
and there is evidence the statistics
show
that the
river came is polluted and it does
affect human beings as well but the
promise is there that this is also part
of the 25 year plan and uh you know
i don't have quite a way to pray as a
question but i
can guarantee that
and i know it's difficult getting
funding out of the company that that
will still continue
because that would absolutely solve the
whole problem
of
the flooding of the water and pollution
and
i so my question is and how far how well
is the um
uh
plans
or is that the number of raw prisons how
long will the plans be to get
the river the pollution issues and to a
virtually safety thing
level
because i think we've got a table them
due to six
i went to an excellent um environment
agency and student thing
for teams
and
then they give us some wonderful figures
that's why i'm here to listen
uh is progress being made because i know
the government tells you to do things
but i understand that the funding can be
very difficult
um can anybody take this question
i can try
david if you go and i'll i'll come in
that way i will try to answer yeah um
in the simplest form is progress being
made yes
um
you also made a link between sort of
environmental
targets um and health public health and
and they're very different things
for which
the environment agency does not have a
remit
so as i said in my presentation
we are required to
monitor what the statute asks us to
monitor and report on the targets that
that provides us with
in that respect
progress is being made
in that we see
um
[Music]
certain elements improving
as works get put in place either with
landowners or with the company
that's not always reflected in
compliance as such and reporting on
compliance because there's a very
confusing mechanism for compliance where
no matter how good most of the elements
are if one's bad they all fail so
it's not a true reflection therefore of
of the improvement in certain aspects
overall things are improving um we do we
do make steady progress
but i will always say there's always
more to do and with
more support either by other
organizations or by public and partners
we can still get more done um and one
way we're doing that is through
the sort of implementation of sort of
integrated solutions so that we're
working across flooding and
natural environment processes
because the two are complementary
one
resolving flooding issues through
you said i think you said leaky dams it
was a bit unclear i couldn't quite hear
um as your flooding protection also
provide water quality protection at the
same time so
the drive towards nature-based solution
and more catchment and holistic
approaches to resolve
water resources water quality and sort
of flood relief at the same time
is a direction we are certainly moving
in and it's giving us
improvements along the way but that
includes that result relies on us
getting partnership buy-in and work with
other organizations
they all have to be resourced and they
all have to have
remits that are aligned to ourselves so
it's not a an easy fix but it it it is a
steady progress yes
thank you
if i could just
davidson i think the environment act is
one of those act that's going to make a
step change in what
the regulator
needs to do what off what need to do
what the water companies need to do
there's a real strong focus we've done
the underpipe stuff we've you know
treatment treatment compliance is 99 100
you know we we know that we do that well
the focus is now on those things that
are um catchment wide which is the storm
overflows which are complex things to
resolve but the environment act i think
encapsulates those issues on the back of
the increased public interest
that the public have in the environment
and i think it's i think it's really
important and david touched upon it
sometimes we need a legislative driver
in order in order to enable us to
um
i would say attract the funding enable
off what to enable us to raise the
funding in order to do things
without that legislative driver
sometimes our hands are tied regarding
the funding that we can put into things
so i would say the environment act is
gonna is gonna create a step change
on the back of that that's why we've um
recently published our environmental
strategy in waterfield which is on our
website which explains our response to
that the next thing is to be held
account in delivering it and i'm sure
this
this meeting as well as a number of our
other stakeholders and partners will be
holding each of us to account in terms
of our ability to deliver against those
commitments
thank you thank you
councillor york
yeah thank you very much alan for
answering those questions i don't know
whether it's like dave you might be able
to provide some sort of written
responses in
maybe a little bit more detail in some
cases if needed um
you uh expressed some concern over the
planning system um and obviously whilst
you're not a statutory consultant
um
obviously
we as obviously both district
authorities are currently in the process
of doing a joint local plan review and i
don't know if there are any members in
the room here who are actually part of
that review
team but are
southwest water involved with that
our development services team will be um
will be party to those conversations
what i meant by being statutory
consultee is that there's there's no
legal requirement
for the local planning authority to
consult with us but we take that
opportunity because we believe it's the
right thing to do and we think
through the work through working with
the environment agency and understanding
the current and future pressures we can
then understand what we need to do in
terms of our future investment in order
to address that planning so
ideally it would be great i'm saying is
personally known um it would be good if
we were a statutory consultant
what that actually means in practice is
i don't know but we're part of that
we're part of the local planning process
and our development customer services
team will be part of that conversation
well that's great today thank you very
much
[Music]
councillor brenton please thank you um
last week's journal you have a whole
um article from your ceo susan davey in
which
she says that we've achieved 100 bathing
water quality right across the region
you you've mentioned that as well
and when i spoke to one of the elite
members of
surface against sewage
he laughed basically he said well yeah
of course because you're not monitoring
the way it used to be done i.e in
different spots different times etc etc
is it once i'm not sure the
technicalities
he was saying basically
not using the same criteria now what
worries me about all this is that you
know you talk about defra being
the main people who were
setting the rules we're no longer in the
eu it was the eu that got us here in
biddeford and uh
the western coal the
high standards which men said would have
had to put in a decent um treatment
works at cobra
that was the eu
criteria we wouldn't have got it we in
fact
took
sexualized water to a public inquiry
that was a long time ago i have to say
whatever battle that was
another lesson achieved and but it's
still not good and i can speak from
experience as far as you know i'm
looking at the evidence of my own armies
i do crawling down westeros or i swim in
the sea i talked to certain surfers
they're getting what
increasingly what we used to get years
ago namely surfers ear which is an
infection to get through getting in
polluted waters i'm not convinced that
our water quality is improving
and why i asked about the business of
the food monitors
you've talked about the water council i
don't know who they are who these people
are they're not local i don't know them
you don't have that
accountability local accountability
going into southwest water
your comments please
yeah david i'll start and then maybe you
follow on from an environment agency
perspective um
i i don't agree with the comment from
the member service against sewage
actually the the
water quality monitoring
locations have remain remained unchanged
for a significant period therefore there
is a significant baseline against which
we can monitor
improvements or stagnation or
reasons where water quality has not
improved
those are laid down and they're very
though all of those locations are
available on the agency's uh gov dot uk
website on the baiting profiles page and
that'll tell that will tell everybody
exactly where those locations are and it
will provide all of the data
that is collected from that
interestingly enough the standards have
actually got tighter over time when the
bathing waters directed was first um
put in place
these standards for e coli and for fecal
streps
were lower than they currently are and
the way in which the uh compliance is
now
assessed is actually tougher to meet
excellent
so again i'm not quite sure what the uh
what your your colleague them surface
against sewage is is indicating that
said
um i think it's i think it's important
that we don't stand still
there are cert there are more things
that we can do and i i wonder whether or
not the instances of surface air and i i
can personally say i've had it and i'm
partially deaf in my right ear but that
was when i was surfing off-building
cornwall in the mid 70s when nothing was
treated
i can say no that that situation has
improved but to make a step change when
i go back to what i said about the
environment act to make a step change in
the environment there are certain things
in the environment act what that will
mean that as a water company we need to
make ambitious targets and we need to
make improvements regards to storm
overflows
reflecting what david said though it's
not all about the water company doing
something the reasons for non-compliance
against the water framework directive
are from other sources and there'll be
other reasons why surfa occurs and that
could be come from other sources not
necessarily i might be talking too much
into david's area david so anything you
want to add to what i've said
i think i can really um
i i would equally disagree with the
tech moment about the context in which
this surface against sewage person made
his comment but the standards that apply
currently to our bathing waters are
exactly the same as they were before we
left the eu
the legislation was directly translated
into uk legislation
so until there's a legislative change
we we as the monitoring authority
are told where to monitor how to monitor
how often to monitor what to monitor for
that has not changed since the
bathingwat directive was implemented
it's been improved over the time the
standards have tightened
i think last time
and and so
alex wright is now much more difficult
to achieve sufficient standards than it
was previously
so i don't know what he was
the context in which he made those
comments of what he was actually
referring to
but it that nothing has changed in that
respect and the quality has by and large
improved to the point where we have now
got 100 compliance
uh that is factual that's not that's not
even a subjective view from one
organization or another
used to be a bathing water area it no
longer is why is that either you know
the river quality is not
poor and it is poor compared to what it
used to be horsey belly for example no
longer has flatfish uh breathing there
yeah something's going on here which
doesn't sound right
i can comment on things so david told me
to comment on him today because i was
part of the conversation when i was at
the environment agency and that was
because the majority of the impacts were
coming from agriculture
and therefore any improvements to the
sewerage system may or may not have
actually had an impact in the overall
water quality instead
in addition to that my understanding
that instead is a tidal location is
actually quite a dangerous place to um
bathe in because of the currents and
therefore there would have been some
health and safety considerations
regarding the absence or reduction in
flat fish um
you could argue i could argue that could
be because of a number of reasons
including climate change so i think
there's a number of factors to be
involved here and that's why the
environment agency collect that evidence
to provide that
unbiased assessment environment
environmental impact and as a regulator
they then ask us to do things to make
those improvements
there's always difficulty in
comparing
should we say uses of the water
environment whether it's a fishery use
or a bathing use um or what have you
and thinking one
compares to another in terms of an
indicator of the health and inverted
commas of that environment
um
we couldn't possibly conflate a lack of
flat fish to a bathing water quality
surfer's ear and whether or not the
bathing water should still be a bathing
water
and
you know insto was designated
because of the entrenched nature of the
the influences on it certainly wasn't
all southwest water it was by and large
to catchment
um
and the process of of the sorry the
legislation for bathing waters has the
process of de-designation if bathing
water quality
is poor for a significant time
then it can be designated from being a
bathing water
and surface again back to the surface
again sewage comet really that we only
monitor and report on designated bathing
butters if if their comment is related
to
not not monitoring where people swim
that's a completely different matter and
and often gets confused but it shouldn't
be confused people swimming somewhere
isn't the bathing water designated
bathing water under the regulations is
where we monitor and report and they can
be very different places
thank you i'll change the subject
slightly i mean i
actually he's right what he says about
insto it was definitely the thing there
was agriculture run off
um
i'm sort of interested i was looking at
the
death ra
defer and and the um
report that came in 2018 actually about
surface water management and obviously
local authorities
have had reduced funding
year on year
for many years
and as you know we don't clear drains
very often
and how that impacts yourselves
and how you work together to to try and
improve that
that situation i just wonder whether
i
refer to the coffees i don't know if the
gentleman has joined us since i asked a
question to tell us what percentage of
the profits
of circles would have put into
into
all the safety and resilience
and i i just feel interested in your
comments around that
you
chair would you like me to i i i'll
repeat i'll reflect back the question so
i so i understand i understood it so
um what part of our profits are put back
into maintaining and ensuring the
resilience of
those
brazilians in the training system the
waterways okay
yeah um i can't answer that question
specifically i'm not the finance expert
but um the our annual performance report
would all have all that information in
available
which would describe
the the budget that we hold how that
money is spent
etc etc um unfortunately i'm not a
finance accountant and i if i quoted
figures they would be incorrect
and given this is a formal meeting i
wouldn't watch it wouldn't wish to um
quote incorrect figures counselor
apologies if i can't answer that direct
any other questions
sorry
i mean obviously are you working i mean
obviously government are expecting the
world of companies
and the local authority to work together
in minimizing surface water runoff do
you feel that that relationship is
working well
uh okay i can answer that we have we
have the um
we have an obligation to produce
drainage waste weight drainage
waste management plans
which take into consideration the
impacts of current future developments
within catchment so yes um we are
producing those strange wastewater
management plans now which will look at
what will our strategic investment look
like going forward we also
provide those to the environment agency
and they will review those against any
obligations that they're currently aware
of any new obligations that may be
coming up that may be coming through but
it's a very new process councillor um i
don't think we've actually followed the
whole drainage and waste water
management plan process through yet so
it's a bit overwatch this space at the
moment but the concept and theory i
couldn't argue with is putting it into
practice and i think at the moment all
relevant partners are working together
really well
anybody else
councillor haines please
thank you very much for a great
presentation
um
yeah i was just sort of pursuing the
storm drainage thing and i was just
looking at figures here the south west
water
i think it's in terms of the monthly
hours of release of storm drainage
i think it's measured like that comes in
the fourth southwest water was the
fourth worst in the country was raw
sewage villages into rivers
in
2021
i think did you say that there is a plan
to reduce storm drainage towards
[Music]
and he doesn't clarify how you're going
to do that is it through like better
storage and
with sort of separating uh water
[Music]
fourth worst or middle of the pack
however however one would like to phrase
it it all depends on the number of event
duration monitors that each water
company has in place that's the first
thing
it also depends on the operability of
those event duration monitors so if you
have an eventuation monitor that's only
operable 10 of the time you'll only
measure those spills that happen within
that ten percent our operability is um
incredibly good
um in fact i think we are one of the
higher performing companies therefore
the more we monitor the more we measure
the more likely are we we are to pick up
spills
so there are a number of things that you
could read into that figure
and we are working with the environment
agency to get to a common standard which
means all of our edms operate for 90 of
the time and then you can make those
decisions around whether or not there is
the ability to compare across water
companies
that said to answer your second question
we have made a commitment that by 2025
will reduce the harm on river water
quality
from our assets by a third and by 2030
to reduce to zero the harm from our
activities
that information is currently being
worked through and you've gone through a
variety of options that i would have
come back to you on in terms of
increased storm storage
you may want to operate your systems in
a different way you may want to put
natural base solutions in
you may want to remove the right for
people to connect automatically to a
sewerage system you may have a number of
options that you may wish to consider
but to answer your specific question no
the plan isn't written down in detail at
the moment we are currently working that
through
and part of those conversations are
happening as i mentioned earlier on
between susan davey our ceo and off what
to explain our ambition to ensure that
it can be funded in the way that we
would hope it could be funded
[Music]
of sewage spillages into the sea um in
terms of the summer bathing season
but it's not all going to do it in the
winter does southwest water do so
is that the situation that there are
warnings
yes there is there are two ways of
warning one is an environment agency
warning process which is pollution risk
forecast i'll let david talk about that
our warning is called beach live soon to
be renamed beach like 2 or something
similar which looks at the real-time
warning of when our csas operate and
therefore the potential to impact
debating water quality
david do you do a pollution broadcasting
process
yes um pollution risk forecasting uh is
related to designate your bathing waters
and it's a model by which we take
weather conditions um tidal states and
predict the likelihood of
the bathing water not being compliant
for a number of reasons whether that be
catchment sources or whether it be
through a
point or diffuse source from the
sewerage infrastructure
that that modeled prediction
is tested against the samples that are
taken as course of the monitoring
throughout the season um and it is
relayed to the local authority and with
the beach owners
and operators so they can provide
signage
and so that they can provide the
warnings from a from a health point of
view
and that but that
i think part of the question was does
that happen outside of the bathing
season well our production our pollution
prediction does not happen outside of
the bathing season it doesn't happen
because we won't have the monitoring to
back up
and to ensure that the predictions are
correct so it'd be a bit of a false flag
to
be trying to predict something without
having the monitoring to back it up
thank you councillor
um
it's water charges to the customer
um
you haven't got the power to cut water
off to anybody if they understand the
regulations even somebody doesn't pay
and we are facing a huge hike in energy
prices how are you going to deal with
the debt that you won't pay to find from
some customers now in the coming months
i i think i caught most of that you
broke up it was about
um water charges is that right
yeah it's about the water charges of
customers yeah there's a
crisis
you guys can't cut water off legally as
they understand it to any customer i
might have got that information wrong i
don't think you've got the power like
the
electric companies can cut
the electric off to somebody
so what are you going to do if there is
a choice and somebody keeps taking your
water
and doesn't pay for it what's going to
happen
the average cost of our water charges is
actually going down this year so we're
the probably the only essential provider
of services where the average cost is
going down
i think it's 10 pounds per bill it's not
a lot but it's not a 300 increase like
it is in energy bills
um so that's the first thing you're
absolutely right counsellor sorry i
can't recall your your name but um we do
have a process in which we work with the
customers to ensure that they can still
be provided with um
drinking water um because it is
essential for life so let's let's not be
around the bush it is
and then we can also help and point them
to relevant other services for example
the citizens sit get my teas in place
the citizens advice bureau and other
supporting agencies as well
from that because southwest water has
got the highest charges of any water
utility
and we've got one of the lowest
household incomes so there is
two sides of a situation here of a coin
that's very difficult for many of our
consumers
in
and north devon as well i'm
saying that from that point of view so i
am concerned i'd be very interested to
see
how your arrears on water charges go in
the next 12 months
guys ask a
um
obviously district councils are are we
have a joint local plan between us
would you prefer we built a new town so
you put a new sewage system in or are
you happy with little bits and pieces
around the existing settlements that
feed into old systems now we're putting
together a new plan at the present
moment
which would you go guys for would you
gonna have a plan for a new town
i would not want to wish to provide a
yes or no answer to those we will look
at whatever the local planning authority
are proposing in terms of their
developments
the environment agency will then look at
the potential impacts on the environment
we will respond accordingly and that
will that that may be that we would wish
to provide a new works
upgrade works serving particular
communities etc etc i don't think it's
fair for me to comment upon that so i'm
sure as a local planning authority you
may well have similar different or
opposing views
i think you've done excellent job thank
you gentlemen both of you um you've
really done a good job of answering the
questions
um i wouldn't like to fill in your shoes
but obviously you know your stuff really
thank you both for taking this
and presenting to us tonight
yeah i'd like to echo all of those
sentiments thank you very much indeed
yeah
thank you any questions
more detail karen will forward to you
and um you know give you an opportunity
to reply but once again thank you for
your time take care
thank you
thank you for the opportunity thank you
thank you goodbye
if there are any questions you wish to
have more detail too
please forward them to karen we'll
coordinate that for you